e
e e
so I'm going to uh open the subcommittee
work session on House Bill
1272 um hopefully the other member of
the subcommittee will get here and
direct report and he should be here at
some point but I think I think we can
proceed um this is the bill
on
reciprocity uh
and you know as I'm reading it um it
strikes out the language um the
substantially similar as to you know
which licenses will will uh permit you
know licensing by endorsement from and
and as I recall some of the stuff that
was raised last time other than you
know you know we just passed that we
just passed the rest proy that's there
now and they're have in the middle of Ru
making
um and there were concerns about
particular licenses in particular as I
call Realtors land
surveyors
um and naturopaths because natural paths
are very different here in and in other
states they can do a lot more here I
spoke with director Courtney I mean I'll
let her speak for herself when she gets
here but my understanding is that
uh you know because they have a very
different scope of practice they
wouldn't be recognized as equivalent
licenses anyway and so there wouldn't be
an option for I don't know if you can
speak to that Doug or someone someone
can speak to that
just so everyone's aware when I do that
weird chair switch thing I'm actually uh
very hard of hearing in my right ear
based on something that happened to me
as a kid so it's hard for me to hear out
of my right ear so that's not just some
weird control
thing
okay I'll have to remember that never
heard that
particular I may need
it very good comp you don't want it's
not that you don't want anyone on your
right it's a very good compensatory
strategy that you're using as an
ideologist in the past life so yeah
similar if someone's I have trouble
hearing this especially with the
background noise so someone speaking to
me I'll often turn and put my ear
towards their mouth it's not that I'm
ignoring you and turning away it's just
I want to hear what you say I get it
yeah okay um so I guess the the F the
question I have the first one is around
it's a more the more general question is
you know the bill talks about you know
comparing the requirements to get a
license and you know what is the
standard for that how close should they
be but what I was wondering is where is
it defined or how is it decided whether
the scope of practice of the two
licenses are close enough that you even
get to the point of
comparing other
things and is that in rules or what I
think it's an interesting question I I
think the language was designed to be a
little bit flexible because we have 57
professional boards and 200 different
types of licenses and I think the
substantially similar piece is kind of a
board by board question we can go to
them because we have to work in
conjunction with the boards and we're
not cramming things through so it's sort
of we let the subject matter experts
inform sure I get that but I guess the
subst my understanding it may be that
I'm off on this is that the
substantially similar is is um is
talking
about um it's the licensing requirements
so the licensing requirements have to be
substantially similar
now that's kind of tied to scope of
practice you'd hope because you'd hope
the licensing requirements would you
know make some sense with regard to what
are you letting people do but my
understanding um is that before you even
get to comparing the licensing
requirements you have to say is this an
equivalent license or we'd even think
about that and the question is how is
that determined what goes into
that that has been discussion with the
boards as well and
so
um the conversations have been around
mainly those requirements but with
other conversations around what other
states currently have so we're looking
to see what are the license types or the
titles um do they equal what we have
here in New Hampshire if they do not for
example Maine has a sales agent license
and an associate broker license in New
Hampshire we have a salesperson license
and an associate broker license but in
Maine the associate broker is actually a
New Hampshire salesperson so there's
been a lot of legal review through board
counsel discussion with the boards the
associations to say what do these equal
what does this mean um so that way when
we then set those requirements it's an
education piece so that's where we're
using those subject matter experts uh
and those stakeholder Partnerships that
we currently have okay and I I assume um
you know is there something similar
going on with regard to scope of
practice to compare to see if the
licenses I'm assuming you let me know
that they don't have to be identical but
presumably they have to be at least
close enough that it makes sense is that
that's my understanding as well before
even getting to the board that the legal
review is being done so for example like
with natural paths um there hasn't been
a lot of movement forward with what the
rules would be for the requirements
around substantially similar because
we're not seeing a similar substantially
similar scope of practice in other
states for that so there's uh some work
that's being done prior to it even
getting to that rulemaking process okay
so again let's see if my understanding
is correct that that even though doesn't
quite say it in statute you're you're
basically expanding the substantially
similar for licensing requirements to
say you're also going to be looking for
at least substantially similar on scope
of practice types of issues and that I
believe has been a business practice and
operationally what we have been doing um
to do our due diligence uh not based on
right that I mean I'm not objecting that
makes sense but that's not in statute or
in rules is it in rules any process okay
I don't think it's explicitly stated but
it sort of has to be implicit that if
you're going to do reciprocity it has to
be kind of one for one or at least close
maybe
1.1 okay that that I mean looking
through this was that question came up
it's like how do you decide so thank you
for that uh represent mipi thank you Mr
chair thank you I have some
clarification needing in this uh when
you say
reciprocity um is it is there national
standards for these uh professions with
licensing that have a national uh
standards and subsect each state and is
there a way to compare or the Nom I mean
each title is so different that it's
hard to
compare I think you have to go
profession by profession some
professions do have national standards
others are state by state and there's a
website that we used what is the website
I'm completely drawing a blank but they
have done
um is it clear doesn't matter there's a
website that we use uh that does these
comparisons so they'll put the nursing
up there and it'll just go state by
state this is what they require this
type of education this many hours
whatever it may be so there there are
um resources available for us to not
have to do on our own a you know 49
states every time we wanna want to do
this follow up sorry
yeah the other piece is so although
we're doing those comparisons and I'm
sorry I it's the West Virginia research
University something or other uh but it
yeah so we use them and clear which is
our national regulatory membership
agency to assist with the comparison
piece um the the professions that have a
national standard or best practice are
typically those ones that we're involved
in the compacts with or working towards
building those compacts and so that
would be where that National process
would um would come in the this part
when we're talking about reciprocity
within the state is where we are using
those resources to compare state to
state and if I could add to that I mean
does that Source those sources of
information include scope of practice
info on the licenses for the um I I
don't know if we've been provided that
information but I do believe that those
research facilities uh agencies have
looked at that but I'm not sure how
clear that is because I was wondering
where you get how you go about DET you
actually have to look at the detailed
scope of practice in every state when
you're looking at
this um representative yeah reciprocity
is both two-way street correct um you
know I can tell you from my experience
as a speech language pathologist I
started in Massachusetts and I had
National American speech engering
Association accreditation then
Massachusetts and then when I moved to
New Hampshire I had to get all over
again and continuing both States
licensing you know I had to New
Hampshire did not take Massachusetts I
mean it's neighboring and I live in a
border thing
so that kind of hurdle do you you
probably see in a lot of those and that
to me is a Crux of the reciprocity for
our neighboring states in neighboring
right if I can make a comment and and
they can say what whatever I I think
calling this bill relative to occupation
license reciprocity was unfortunate
because I don't the issue I don't think
is reciprocity it's it's licensing by
endorsement um I don't think and I know
there's this feeling of fairness but but
this is
really uh the benefit is not for the
leny the benefit is to make uh more
people available to provide um resources
and services to the people in New
Hampshire while still doing it safely
and that doesn't require you know have
forcing that requiring the other state
recognize ours first does not contribute
to that so I think the idea of putting
getting actual reciprocity in here I
think is not appropriate actually I I
agree with you uh Mr chair that was my
point reciprocity is not you accept mine
and I accept you and it's like helping
the workforce to straddle especially in
the Border towns and it it was a pain to
do two different uh paths when I was
working uh you know I would consult in
Massachusetts bard of town but I had to
you know it was a different cycle New
Hampshire had their own thing did not
take any of the reciprocity whereas you
know Mass chusetts no problem yeah so
that is a big impediment in the whole
language I try to look through there's
really not much addressed in that way Mr
chair that's my concern is the key thing
is reciprocity and I think that is
not the that's not going to alleviate
the problem of Workforce shortage we
could if we decide to move forward with
this bill uh the subcommittee and then
the full committee could consider
changing um the word reciprocity to
licensing by endorsement or something to
clarify that you know but it looks like
or or both um but it is interesting to
point out because line nine individuals
seeking a license by endorsement it's
not in the title but it's in the
language and I think that's sort of
where we're able to you know through the
PLC 313 make those adjustments so that
even if there isn't reciprocity working
with the boards we can get those people
licensed in the state okay so uh thank
you for clarify are treating it as
endorsement as well because of that
because of the word endorsement in that
uh language okay that that helps clarify
I couldn't figure out thank you
representative Schmid or did you have
something thank you Mr chair so I I I
think the the col we that we've been
engaging up to this point has been
helpful and use in terms of
understanding kind of where we're going
uh and what our things uh what our goals
are um and I do agree with the with the
chair's earlier remark that it's to uh
to make um the the situation better for
the people of New Hampshire in providing
services that they can't get because you
got you know uh musical chairs as people
are being left out because we don't have
enough people of our own to take care of
the thing uh and and that is that is
absolutely in the interest of the
citizens of New Hampshire the and I I
want to add to that that that the to my
way of thinking that one of the central
aspects of Licensing is the idea of
protecting the public and not letting
people loose on them that are untrained
I mean the situation in M Missouri for
example as I understand it is they ain't
got Li lensing in Missouri so how do
they have any idea what people are
bringing to the table before they're
it's if it's all buyer
beware I don't that's not the way New
Hampshire has structured its whole
situation for basically the the
certainly the 20 years I've been here
but also I think that the structure that
exists clearly is is has the same idea
protecting the public and it's been that
way for probably a hundred years um so
then it becomes a question of as you
said earlier Doug um that that uh you're
going to have to go profession by
profession because there's some things
where if it doesn't go exactly right
there's no problem uh if you're dealing
with somebody's Health people putting
hands on somebody's body in some fashion
for some service then you got to be sure
that you have the criminal background
checks and all those things for
protecting the public so you have to to
do it profession by profession and one
final thing in that is that a body is a
body in Arizona or in New Hampshire uh
but an architect for example who's used
to designing structures for Arizona may
find some's different in in New
Hampshire from Arizona and vice versa so
then you have to go profession by
profession but uh you know uh and so I
think we're on we're we're heading in
the right direction
and so it's more than just reciprocity
you you recognize me I recognize you
what is the profession and what are the
ramifications of that profession for
providing the service safely and
beneficially to our people
here representative Brown had a question
uh thank you Mr
chair so looking back through my notes
from the first hearing there was a lot
of opposition to this the New Hampshire
Association Realtors the uh licensed
electricians they have reciprocity with
21 States but they oppose this as
written mechanical licensing Chief uh
the board of
accountancy um and a number of others
so because of that I want to be really
clear that I know what I'm doing here
which and I will apologize
to my much more knowledgeable fellow
committee members uh as this is this is
is new to me this
year don't don't worry we were all new
at some point thank you very much Mr
chair I appreciate that um it would I be
accurate in translating this into saying
that licensing requirements include
scopo practice is there are we defining
that that way licensing you want to get
a license in New Hampshire here's your
requirements and that would include
scoper practice or am I wrong I wouldn't
say that's the case I think the
licensing requirements are more the
training the
experience the education those types of
things that you need to obtain licensure
and then once you have that license the
scope of practice sets the parameters on
what you're able to do with that license
okay all right um follow thank you for
that followup yep having although I'm
not experienced in this I did serve on
the New Hampshire Dees Board of
certification for wastewater treatment
plan operators for a number of years and
are are the way that we we compared a
grade six from State X to a grade four
in New
Hampshire Not only was education and
experience but it was also scoper
practice so we had this conversation as
a whole when we sat in committee and
that resolved that now under rules is
that what oplc is going to be
doing I think that goes back to
representative lakes's question earlier
sort of in that first instance when we
do a license by license comparison that
would be where we would take a look at
the scope of
practice and one more followup follow up
and I'm not supposed to ask you of your
opinion do you feel that that process
answers some of the questions some of
the the hesitation from the boards on
this
bill I know that's a that's a broad
question but no that's I'm not sure how
much that question about scope of
practice relates to this the proposed
language in this bill because I think
the proposed language in this bill is is
saying that there does not if we remove
the substantially similar requirements
for licensing it lends more towards um
what was initially what was said prior
of the you just need to have a license
in this state to be able to come to New
Hampshire it doesn't matter what their
requirements are um which also would
effect how we operationalize that by
looking at the scope of practice and it
would not necessarily require us to do
that either that's actually useful I
hadn't thought about so so your take is
that if we got rid of the substantially
similar it would remove or at least
limit the the uh look into the relative
scope of practice I mean I think they
have to have
somewh and I don't know if this is a
question you can answer but um I I don't
know if it would I and I haven't thought
about this but my my initial reaction is
that if we're still the requirement
would still be if you're licensed in a
state to do X and you're trying to do X
in this state okay we would still have
to make that comparison in some regard
right so I even if regardless of this
language I think that consp comparison
would still have to happen Okay but I
don't I don't know I haven't thought
about it long okay and just
uh oh just just not directly on this
bill but uh you know I don't know it
might make sense it's more a comment on
the rul making to actually put something
in the rules about how you're deciding
whether or not whether the two are even
comparable and you're going to do this
but I don't have a strong feeling on it
but it might would have clarified things
when I was looking at it represent M py
uh thank you Mr chair um another
question um this is not excluding
Licensing in New Hampshire you have to
have licensing in Massachusetts for
example in apply for licensing it's just
the reciprocity is what the you know
educational needs or continuing
education some of it you know if we do
it in one state we don't have to do it
again in another state to keep that
continuity right so speak follow another
followup followup yeah so in a border
towns you know it was brought to my
attention that Physicians who see
patients from Massachusetts there's no
problem with insurance covering their
visit to their Physician's office in
Nashua they are coming from
Massachusetts and but the physicians in
now New Hampshire cannot do tele
medicine to their patients in
Massachusetts because there is no
reciprocity in their practice which C
kind of makes it similar to what I faced
as a speech language
pathologist you know would this address
some of it because Massachusetts takes
National thing New Hampshire does not
participate in the federal registry or
federal licensing
for medical not in
this uh thing so there's lot of little
gaps
so it's creating problem for people in
border
cities the the way that we're I think
and Doug can um follow up but if this
was to pass with this language my
understanding is you would still have
that same issue if they didn't apply
this is still saying that they have to
apply for lure in New Hampshire so even
if you have your license in
Massachusetts you would still have to
apply for that license here in New
Hampshire it sounds like this this
particular issue isn't it it's Mass
actually that's preventing her from
practicing it's not New Hampshire right
so it would be a mass thing Mass would
say Mass would say yes we can you know
they don't object if the insurance is
willing to pay but New Hampshire
prohibits them from PR practicing tele
medicine going this way going that way
so because there's you know the
standards here is higher whatever it is
because we don't participate in the same
Federal registry and there are some
conversations with many of our medical
boards medicine mental health um
psychology around teleah health and so
that may be a conversation on the rule
making around teleah health because
there are some caveats to that okay just
to clarify my thought uh Mr chair is I'm
very aware I mean I'm all for you have
to be licensed in both States in order
to practice it's just that if one state
saying you're qualified you can do it
why do I have to do the whole set again
for and New Hampshire that's the biggest
challenge I feel in New
Hampshire that is to me is the
reciprocity representer
Brown thank you Mr chair so coming back
to
you if you're licensed in New Hampshire
and you want to do tella Health in Mass
it it can't be New Hampshire that's
saying you can't do that it has to be
Massachusetts
right no because you're licensed in your
practice scop of practice in New
Hampshire you're seeing the patient from
Massachusetts here it's okay for you to
see that in person but if the same
patient is across the border New
Hampshire board says I would suggest
taking this offline it's an interesting
but I think this is
I I I I don't think it does it would be
an issue if the if there was a doctor
that came up from Massachusetts to here
but this doesn't really deal with teleah
health which is why I suggest taking it
um so kind of a question with the
committee is what do we want to do with
this um I don't have a set view on that
at this point I mean I certainly support
much have a comment sure can I one more
thing that this is a fairly new bill as
is and the office was tasked with
drafting rules we have one set of
interum rules in place um but we have a
public hearing on the PLC 313 stemming
from this uh statute on I believe March
7th so we haven't even had an
opportunity yet right I was actually
just going to make that comment okay I
just wanted to yeah and and uh
so we got sent I don't know if anybody
had a chance to look at I skimmed
through them you know there are proposed
rules on reciprocity um um you're not
done with all the professions yet is
that correct or are they all cover no
not yet it it we're doing it rolling so
the the rules we did propose I think the
interim rules had 12 or 15 of the boards
covered and the the new proposed rules
have significantly more but I don't have
a number off the top of my head so so
given that um and I know there is some
concern that um there you know there
appears to be in the current law that
was put in place last year a lot of
discretion the executive director and
while we may believe that director
Courtney is going to do the right thing
you know can't predict who's going to be
there in the future so I that's part of
I think the motivation behind this
however you know once it's in rules it's
got some inertia so what I was wondering
is do we really need this
now um you know let the blw from last
year sort out let them finish the ru
making and then if in the future there
are um
problems or concerns saying well they're
really too restrictive and there we
should you know there should be things
that reply by
endorsement um that uh I see you um that
um you know where we should be
recognizing we're not I mean the
legislature can step in and fix it at
that point um so just thoughts on that
I'll get to you with Mama but
representative
G thank you Mr chair I've been listening
and trying and I came to the exact same
conclusion is that this my question is
can't this be handled through
rules and so I really like what you're
saying is that let's listen to let's
finish the rul making process that we're
engaged in hear what those rules are and
and I'm ready to make a motion to I on
this um okay is there a
second yeah then we'll have discussion
yeah so I I agree I think you seconding
motion correct I can second the motion
and I think we can uh all agree or at
least in my mind it's more clear it's
too premature to change everything all
at once before knowing what the big
changes rul making hasn't happened this
year which came last year and so you
don't know what is affecting in a
positive way what's not affecting before
we get one Clarity that was a huge
change from oplc
in the
board regulatory boards to divide the
responsibility and if you have something
brief man we're just running a little
late
um the point I wanted to make is uh
director Courtney is a significant
player in all of this can we find out
whether she's going to be here or not
because but if we're if we're moving in
the direction of itl already then it's
not so crucial but otherwise can we find
out whether she's going to make it we
can't commit her to no but I'm just
trying to find out I mean I joked with
her that uh that she she's not permitted
to uh either resign or
die but unfortunately that's not
enforcable if we're going in the
direction of itl anyway then I think
we're we're not in as much of a bind to
have her here so thank you any any other
discussion on the represent Brown thank
you Mr chair I will try to be brief y
so we do have
reciprocity now am I correct in saying
that we have a licensing by endorsement
process that was um the Sor Authority
was given to the office after the last
legislative session and we've started
developing rules with the boards and
commissions as noted in the previous
bill with their consultation so we have
some
um rules that have been uh adop been uh
interim rules that have been adopted and
we have another public hearing coming up
in March so we are currently F starting
that process for the licensing by
endorsement and followup followup is
that eventually going to get to a point
out uh through the rules where someone
can say to a PLC I have a license here
in X state for this and you
automatically say here's your license
for that in New Hampshire without any
conversation that's reciprocity to me
actually we right if I I can we were
emailed um their proposed the interim
rules um on Reciprocity for the
professions that they've already
reviewed and you can look through it it
is asking for more information that I
would have expected but we don't need to
get into the details of of commenting on
on the rul making but it didn't look
unreasonable so but if you want to look
at the details and my take my thing is
this if we itl it um you know this is is
the end of the second year and so it it
we we're not going to bind what's going
to happen the new legislature next year
so you know if it turns out that the
legislature or anybody any member who
wants to put a bill in thinks that the
rules are not appropriate or they're not
being executed properly they can put a
bill like this or whatever in at that
time to fix it but yeah I'm I'm on R ony
and then G um thank you Mr chair so the
uh licensing by endorsement is already
it was in last year's thing so this is
not necessary this bill is not necessary
for that process to be unfolded correct
correct okay you're asking them for an
opinion though so you got to watch out I
took the question to be clear as do we
need this to have that process right
take place yeah we have a bunch of new
people on the committee we we we slogged
through all of this last year and uh
and yeah that was put in place last but
it was very clear Mr chair when they
said that endorsement was so that makes
me feel good okay yeah great
representative Gould I was just going to
say hopefully if if um there are
Representatives who are concerned about
this the outcome of the rules making
they attend some of the public hearings
and give their input okay um on the
subcomment any further discussion or can
we move to a vote okay um so the motion
is itl on House Bill
1272 um all in favor I anyone opposed
okay that's 5 to Zer I'm closing the
subcommittee work session on House Bill
1272 and I'm going to open the the work
session on House Bill
1410 and give me a moment to get
organized
here
yeah when do you have to
leave when do you have to
all right
well we we'll try and I'm hoping we can
do that although we'll see yeah that's
how much people want to talk and
questions and all that which I don't
want to limit but right okay
so this ask a question certainly for
oplc if if you could come up with those
two websites that you mentioned I was
trying to look up clear and I couldn't
find anything could you email us to us
that would be great thank you okay just
trying to get this I will say I'm not
sure if you're going to be able to get
the information I think there a
subscription type is that true so I'm
not sure you'll be able to but I can we
can at least tell you what they are
thank
you okay um I sent out two emails to
everybody one was um my notes on what we
chose to do at the last meeting and we
went through M most of the bill and
actually took votes on what to do on all
you know a bunch of the sections we were
left
with um dealing with some of the section
you know the repeals in in uh section 10
and we had asked uh Mr asout to to
provide some input on that which he did
and then I sent an email out kind of so
hopefully making it clear and
summarizing it um and I sent that email
out and so what I would suggest
is we can go through that
list um you know the email I sent out if
that's
okay and we can talk about um the pieces
and and and then we can we can vote on
pieces um and then once we're done I'll
take everything we've decided on both
days and go down to oplc and dump it all
on them to turn it into one Amendment
okay so does everyone have it was the
email I sent out on the 29 9th at I
think it's 5:41
p.m what's that I don't
have
okay um I you know I
can and and this is mostly going to
be right but this that's the minutes and
we um I mean if anyone as I put in the
email if anyone thinks I made a mistake
please bring it up on that one um the
29th yeah the 29th one which is um where
to go with the last part we didn't deal
with then and this is um this is all I
believe on pages six and a little bit on
seven of hb1
so that's the no u but you can we can
kind of share this if you want if you
don't have it I yeah I could I didn't
print extra copies of this
one no no at this point
um yeah I don't have but I I can I can
talk it through that works um okay so
the first part is on Section 10 page six
it's lines 27 and 28
so um this one you know
what actually let me get a piece of
paper so I can actually go like last
time do so I got them I got a stack of
them here in the back of one of
these and one actually it's this one
because I knew I was going to have to do
this all
right um I just have one clarification
with that one so um that is we are going
to
repeal medical technicians no I that's
going to keep it at that we decided last
time that's those lines are not MediCal
oh actually hang on a minute 20 no I'm
saying we we already did that that's in
the minutes from the last meeting yeah I
said we were going to remove that from
the bill so we would leave the medical
technicians in
statute I believe okay so I I wrote it
as keypad and then I wrote it as removed
so my own notes is confusing to me yeah
let me so that was lines 22 it's already
right and I
think then we said remove from the
repeal list 25 and 26 that's the
Radiology let me find out don't repeal
it yeah 20 I have removing 25 through
26 um which is um the medical imaging
ones right and the and the radi um yeah
Radiology Radiology so if you look at
the email I sent on the 26th um second
it second Bullet From The Bottom it says
page 10 section 10 Page 6 lines 25
through 26 motion remove these lines
from the bill keeping the licensing of
medical and radiation therapy
representative G made the motion Bailey
seconded and you know we had the vote
and it passed so so we're going to leave
that in there that's okay stays in
statute correct that stays in statute we
had all this confusion we're moving for
the bill statute and all that so yeah
yeah so that is that is what we Ed and
that's can you just clarify for me then
the one two and
three on for the this is from 10 L you
know line 22 23
24 that will be repealed from the
statue um the medical technician that we
V let go sure I'm speaking correctly um
not 22 that's different that's medical
technicians that's not the rate the the
radiation and IM not the Imaging people
correct no that I'm clear with the
Imaging which is 25 26 is fine we are uh
removing it from the repeal list right
so it's staying in the stat and we
looked at 22 and 23 I believe and 24 all
three are medical
technicians I think we said we were
going to strike that from the bill from
the bill because medical technicians no
I no no I had that's keep it that's
going to be repealed right and actually
I may have made an error that in my in
in my
motion okay no this is and it should be
leave I think and you correct me if if
your memory is different than so yeah
with with what I sent in the email
actually on the 26th and that that's one
two third from the bottom is actually an
error um and if anyone disagrees that's
fine that should have been leave this
section in the bill as is for lines 22
through 24 I made the motion I wouldn't
have it was something different and
representative G seconded and it was
unanimous oh it was leave it so I okay I
I I made an error in my email of the 26
and thank you for catching yeah that is
we we are leaving it yeah actually it
says remove these lines from the bill
but then it says in my email eliminating
the registration medical technicians
which that doesn't you know it's in
Conflict so the first part was um
correct leave the section in the bill as
is but thank you for
that
okay
certainly on the medical technicians one
and I don't recall that we had this
conversation but I talked to Jackie
about what we were doing what we were
looking at and and my question to OPC is
is it important for us to keep the
registry as I recall the issue was that
that she's getting complaints there's no
active board there's a problem
recruiting board members there's no way
to adjudicate the complaints if they
don't rise to the level of a criminal
proceedings but do we want to keep a
registry of known problems e and then
remove the board have it be an opl
function to have a registry I don't
think it's necessary because as
executive director Courtney testified
there aren't individuals who identify as
this position so it's either it could be
contractual it could be covered under
another board there's other places this
could be handled I do think she made the
suggestion if we decided to keep the
registry to give it to oplc so that we
could follow through with those
hearings um I mean what what I I you I
mean I think maybe what I discussed last
time what I would say is you know what
I'd suggest and we can make a different
decision is to to leave those in the
bill which would remove the registration
and then in a future Bill if somebody
thinks that there really is a problem
you know work with oplc to figure out
okay what is the process that should go
forward because the current one is
completely dysfunctional and can't work
because nobody identifies that
profession nobody wants to be on the
board they have one person on the board
the board has never met and therefore
they cannot act on anything and there's
no interest I guess from what she told
us in anyone being on it so it just
doesn't work the way it's that's no good
right and so you know if later somebody
can come up with a a way that would work
then you know can be considered and I
don't want to try and solve that as part
of amending this bill at this point
is uh my to clarification on that one is
if we
repeal the board of registration of
medical technician and medical
technician registration and all that
relating to medical
technician is there a process then
nobody's identifying as that but they're
working as a medical
technician in the hospital or in the
field so who's overseeing
that could be the employer and there's
also depending on the profession it
could be within the scope of practice of
the
individual one more followup Mr CH
certainly so does that come under
licensed nurse pra uh LNA
or so if a Medtech
LNA violated some form of disciplinary
rule the Board of Nursing would have
jurisdiction over that okay so this is
not that but they they wouldn't be I
mean a mettech
LNA is is practicing as an LNA correct
and not and they not a medical
technician so they wouldn't be under
this anyway and just one other question
if you know so director Courtney said
they had gotten some complaints but she
couldn't do anything unless it was
clearly criminal and then she could
refer it to law enforcement but who's
making those complaints what sort of
people that's not something I can reveal
those are confidential can you even say
is
it is it the is it the employer I don't
know I'm not asking who yeah yeah yeah
but I still don't I don't know the
information even if I no what sorry yeah
I represent go good disclose thank you I
recall specifically um director Courtney
saying that she could not report some of
these to the employer because if the
board did not adjudicate the report then
her hands were bound so I don't think
they're only coming from the employer or
even you know there was nothing
indicating any of them were coming from
the
employer bottom line is what we talked
about is we're talking about
housekeeping people th that those kind
of scenarios where they had access to
Medicine and I I agree with you if this
is a problem going forward then a
clearer bill separate from this can come
you but a men py and then Schmid thank
you Mr chair so if this is repealed
there's no board there's no registration
the
employer can take action um I can ask
specifically the exitor hospital or poou
Hospital which it was exitor hospital
that was public and if this was in place
the exitor hospital could deal with
that right
away just let me we don't have control
over how the employers would be dealing
with their employee relationships so you
know how that partnership would be
handled but she asked if it could and
presumably they could so just removing
this barrier with no place to go like a
dead end uh you know in terms of uh
complaints and who's going to look at it
does now oplc feels like they have a
tool to say okay they won't come to oplc
with complaint the employer can deal
with it with their own because there's
no licensing or
registration I don't think from the
employer's perspective that this would
be seen as a barrier I think the problem
here is this this doesn't really provide
much utility I think whether this exists
or not the employer could take action
against that
employee and and I mean the you know the
the uh bad behavior could be noticed I
suppose either by a patient um the
employer uh practitioner at the employer
or
whoever and um you know if they're
employed by the facility hospital or
whatever in that case you know plan
could go to the hospital and they're
going to deal with it however they deal
with it I mean ultimately if if the
patient thinks they're harm they can sue
the hospital and that gets into the
whole medical insurance thing but yeah
that was my point like as long as we
keep the Public Safety in mind and this
is going to provide a safer environment
for granite Staters in the field I I
think it's not going to make any
difference um if you know it's not
working so it's not really doing
anything now if we take it out it's not
going to make it in my view at least
more dangerous or safer and there might
be another
solution that might help Public Safety
but this apparently
isn't you I'll set on that
or so um I I think there's it's just
irrefutable that the statement you just
made is the case I mean if it's not
working then no benefits being achieved
I mean but the the bottom line is is not
whether the employer could have done
something uh the employer clearly could
have done something but because there
was no nothing in place Mr Kowski could
come up from and just to from a series
of other states where he was a bad actor
and he was and he got to New Hampshire
One Jump Ahead of the the people
arresting him in States X Y and Z and
probably ABC as well um they they never
would have hired him if they knew what
his background was but there was no
basis for there was no network there was
no registration that was the reason I
was on the committee at the time that
put together the bill in an attempt to
give the give New Hampshire some kind of
um warning network if you will of of
people that had a history in other
states but if it's not working
then we got to go some other direction
okay um so if what I'd like to do is get
back to the male of the 29th which is
the additional pieces no of U of 1410 um
in section 10 if that's okay so the
first
one is um proposing to remove lines 27
and 28 on page
six and these are just you know we we've
done last year maybe even prior a
general move of certain administrative
functions from the boards to
oplc and also there's some disciplinary
you know at least the the the hearings
and other parts of discipline and that
wasn't done in all boards in all 57
boards and so as I understand it you
know um the one online 27 is relative to
collection and expenditure of funds but
that's moved from the boards to oplc and
and related relative to fees and charges
so what this thing does is um it it
removes the authority from the board
we've already given it to oplc now it's
in two places which kind of doesn't work
so
um you know if there if people are when
when people we have discussion but then
I'd like to take just a quick vote on if
people are fine with removing
this you want a motion before we discuss
it sure or yeah what you can do that
okay um um so I make a motion to remove
it okay and I I'll second it just we get
through this um if if we want to remove
the conflicting language we want to keep
this language in the bill because this
is remove the what it says here is
remove these lines from the bill that's
the motion no it's retain the language
yeah it sounds like you might oh no I've
got
this I'm it's okay I'm messed up
here and I'm I'm bur keep keep the
language all right going to be thank you
for keeping me yeah uh not too confused
yeah not confused you have a
staff yeah it's me Mr chair if I can
clarify by keeping it in section 10 it's
going to be repealed correct which means
the language will be removed in the
Statue so the redundancy is gone you are
absolutely correct okay um and uh
well I under I understood that I put the
wrong thing down okay um my apology does
a negative and a negative make a
positive not in this case gu all right
so uh I have a question for oplc Mr
chair sure so you know when uh director
Courtney was talking about with the LNA
licensing if we can get the funds from
DS for licensing and if the you know the
double charging will end will this help
in that case this is kind of an
unrelated matter this is more just
removing conflicting language okay so it
has nothing to do with we we're telling
them to do two different things and
we're cleaning that up okay I hope
sounds okay um so the motion is to keep
these lines in the bill which would
repeal um those two sections of Statute
and um
uh and we have a motion in a second yeah
okay everybody in favor yes anyone
oppose no okay fine we're done with that
one the next one actually is uh
something that was brought to us by uh
Mr oser house
um he's suggests we amend RSA it's 326 B
colon
161 and this is It's a similar thing
it what no it's the 16 sorry it's says
and the current language is submit a
completed application in
fees and this is um as it's just more
clean up because I think right and and
we're adding as established by the board
which is the language used we're taking
out the language established by right
we're removing it um so my suggestion
was the what are we talking about B16 is
to take out that repeal but amend
section one of that language just just
so that it's clear oplc has fee setting
Authority no this is no this is adding
something
new this is adding something
[Music]
new so correct but that
adding um submit a completed
application so my my suggestion
is remove line 9 from the bill which I
believe but then amend section one of
B16 just to remove conflicting fee
setting Authority language and I did not
I it's in the language I sent to
representative L right but I I'm trying
to see if I put it in my notes or okay
you did do that uh Mr chair you said
substitute submit you know you did add
in the word the uh
add to the bill a section to amend RSA
326 DB colon
16 comma one as follows so you did put
this language to be substitute so this
would be to replace line 29 correct is
that or 20 is it
right is it line just a moment is it is
it okay
no what was the question
sorry if we if we're suggesting that we
add language Lindsay just walk in the
door when you great thank you
yeah thank
you all right so
yeah you're you're we got a wonderful
suggestion to
some microphone yeah thank you we got
some wonderful language to add oh Lord
this is so hard my husband's right why
do we not all run out of the room
screaming all right we got a wonderful
recommendation to add some language to
this bill on B16 semicolon 1 I if my
memory serves me correct my question is
other than line 29 on page six is there
anywhere in the other five pages of this
bill we're looking at where the language
is already there and if not where do we
add that language into this
bill so RSA 326 B16 wouldn't have
appeared anywhere else in wouldn't have
it would not have Okay so I do think
it's interesting right because right now
section 10 is repeal exactly straight so
exactly so my suggestion would be remove
line
29 from section 10 and then probably
create a new section where we could do
that Amendment thank you okay and in the
email I had the add a section to change
that line what I had left off was
removing line 29 and I've added that in
my notes and that it would be part of
the motion so than I'll make the motion
somebody can second okay and yeah and if
there's no more discussion the question
is do we remove line 29 which repeals
326 B16 and instead add a section that's
going to amend it to remove the uh the
language is established by the board if
that's what you want to remove that yeah
okay so we don't I need to add that we
just have to remove it from this line
and well we remove line 29 which is the
repeal of the whole section correct and
then we add an amendment to the section
to take out correct the work so I'm
saying think you're going to add another
section out of yeah to the bill so we
don't have to deal with that in this SE
I mean wherever allas puts it in there
not in this section correct correct so
all we have to do right now is to remove
it from repeal line which is well we're
voting to do two things one is to remove
line 29 and also to add the section that
changes the language may I certainly not
in this section no no that's what we're
going to vot do right now but yeah it'll
be added to the bill yeah uh
representative Brown doing two things in
one motion yeah which we can do Mr oer
house would you repeat what you wanted
for my notes for myself because I'm
apparently slow here no that's fine what
you wanted to change in 326 P6 so I
would remove I would remove line 29 from
the bill and then the language I
proposed has fee setting Authority with
the board so I just suggested removing
from the board piece so that it doesn't
conflict with RSA 310 so that would fall
right in line with what we've been doing
in this bill the issue is it says
currently it says submit a completed
application fees as established by the
board but we remove the authority to set
fees from all the boards and gave it to
oplc corre so this is in
Conflict yeah second it's the second
part is going to be added to this bill
in a different section correct cor all
right so all in favor anyone opposed no
okay well actually it's four to
zero because Bailey's not here all right
thank you um do we need to add a section
now or not no no we we voted to do it
okay um so what I'm going to do I'll
take this down to O OS and they'll draft
an amendment and they'll add it wherever
they think appropriate I'm glad to leave
that to
them um and they they also handle things
like if we say remove these lines they
handle the rate of the subsequent lines
and all that we don't have to tell them
to do
that all right
theoretically I I will not say they
there haven't been errors made but
that's supposed to be their job okay um
the next one is um on page six line 30
remove this line from the bill because
we chose to keep the license of lnas and
this is remove something related to
licensing handling LNA applications can
we combine the two 30 and 31 both are
nice uh removing it from the repeal line
I I would ask that we do I mean I could
have done this differently um okay and
but I kind of went through his things in
order and I'm I'm confused enough as it
as I yeah maybe we'll do extra motions
but so wasn't excuse me Mr chair yeah so
may wasn't this because we eliminated
section one from the bill correct right
exactly
right
okay and second
second all any all in favor anyone
oppose no okay fine we got that uh okay
next remove line
31 I
have um
right because we decided to keep the
licenser for LNA so we have to remove it
from being repealed you are are
absolutely correct I believe and tell me
if check check on
us uh actually no no I think we want to
keep here the issue and that's the notes
I put in email I want to leave it in the
bill and keep the repeal because the
lenser by endorsement license renewal
and license reinstate process for all
boards that been moved to oplc so this
repeal needs to remain in the bill even
though we are keeping LNA
licensing but because we moved the
authority now it's another case where we
leave the authority in two places in
statute which is not
great okay with that anyone have
so I move that we remove line 31 from
the bill no that it's the contrary keep
the bill keep the line in oh thank you
yeah
leave these in the bills the motion
leave these in the bill leave line 31 in
the so we don't have to do anything then
we don't have to have a motion because
if you're going to leave it right um we
don't have to technically that's true
this is so confusing so um unless we
voted on I mean just oh yeah to make it
clear on here I mean everybody anyone
opposed to doing this not be formal okay
keeping it to to anyone opposed to
leaving these in the bill no keeping
them okay great yeah I mean some of
these
yeah okay now we're dealing with 34
through
35 and this is I want to remove these
lines from the bill because these deal
with um the LI uh licensing temporary
licensing and continuing ed for nursing
assistance we need to pull the repeals
out because we chose to keep license for
l& I have a question about that uh this
might be to the opl let's
see so this is in response to um this
this question is to oplc if you the line
34 35 36
37 this rule making is being
implemented from last we're we're just
dealing with 34 and 35 at the moment and
because 36 is going to be
different Okay so we're not repealing it
because the shift in licensing process
has been moved to oplc for even lnas
correct um because we deleted section
well be it no it's more an issue that we
don't want to we don't want to
repeal the language for temporary
licenses for lnas or for continuing
education requirements for lnas because
we're keeping elna's license correct but
what the Authority or the due
responsibility was moved to oplc for
licensing purposes from last which rule
making is happening right now am I
correct correct we have the but what the
what these statutes did was say that a
nurse could a licensed LNA could start
practicing um pending the outcome of the
criminal background check so we got
people working faster so so that that
was my yeah if we repeal this then
people who can practice now we get rid
of temporary licenses for lnas which we
don't want to do okay okay so it's
reduced the amount of uh time that's
needed to get licensing for lnas and
they can start practicing right now or
to leave it the same actually because
we're taking the lines from the bill we
leave it the way it is now which is they
can get the temporary license and
practice sooner okay I think okay as
long as the workforce is a ailable
that's and what we talked about is that
um the LNA question is going to be dealt
with by another bill so we're just
taking everything out any changes to any
changes will happen elsewhere we're not
worried about that in this bill or
director Courtney thought she might be
able to do something by rule whatever no
I understand but we decided to keep the
licensing for elenas that was the intent
was to take away that and make it even
easier but it was last discussion with
the background check and all that we
needed to make sure that we're keeping
LNA licensing
and reduce the double dual Channel
regist registry and combine that follow
up
Mr so we we decided at the last one to
we're not doing anything in this bill
with lnaas so any discussion about the
lnas other than to take out
repeals from this bill
just confuses the issue any anything
that is going to change the status quo
will be handled in the future Jackie's
working on that so we can trust Jackie
and we can just let that go and remove
any of the language of the lnas from
this bill right or if you have an
interest get talk to her and get
involved in that process exactly that's
fine EXC me yeah certainly for the
people out that Jack would be
representative groa thank for those out
there yeah we're
sorry keep it move things along be a
little informal but not too much so
thank you for that um yeah so no I I I
agree I did have conversation with uh
representative gr and motion on
[Music]
this okay I move to remove lines uh 34
and 35 from the bill second okay and uh
all in favor anyone opposed
okay good next let me sure look this
over again to make sure I didn't make a
mistake
um relative to injunctive
relief now this was one um that we want
to keep or was there an issue I'm trying
to remember my notes on
this uh I think I've got the original
here we go 36 keep in the bill remove
and actually I had that wrong in my
notes
um actually wait a minute you have both
36 and 37 Le no 36 I have the notes as
different and they may or may not be so
let's deal with them to I I thought I
got this straight but apparently I
didn't which so this is line 30 3 6
which is the injunctive relief thing
b40 um
is keep in the bill because we still
want the language the injunct relief
language around lnas if we're licens in
them I think that your email said keep
in the bill removed from statute keep in
the bill removed from statute there the
disciplinary stuff is because that
covered in10 right this is another one
where the responsibility moved from the
board to so
by by repealing it we are keeping it in
the well it's an issue it's an issue
again where we have the board we gave
the board authority and opl authority
for the same thing which is not good
that's correct correct okay so let me Mr
chair would you accept a motion sure uh
I I move that we REM that we keep we
leave l
30 well just doing uh 36 at the moment
and 37 both about um no 30 37 is a
different it's going to go the other way
we can talk about that separate just
36 36 from the bill okay and I'll second
it all right
any this double negative is driving me
nuts so we'll leave this in the bill
which will repeal the
language giving giving uh the board
certain
Authority because oplc has it so the
statue will change because it's
repealed and the new Statue will cover
what is needed because oplc has the
right this is just repealing redundant
language and statute the board wouldn't
even lose the authority to right
injection anyone oppos to this what is
it we're doing again okay we're going to
leave line 36 page I I know no no
worries page page six line 36 removing
it no we're not removing we're not
removing it we're we're going to leave
it in the bill which will repeal it from
statute correct okay thank you I'm not
the only one no I I've had issues with
this too we we haven't had this uh we
haven't we've gotten the lawyer mindset
maybe which would help us with this I
don't know
um okay the next one are and we only
have uh we only have two more bits here
and I apologize for being running a
little bit late uh to everybody but uh
this is Page Six line
37 um
through Page seven line one the first on
the top and
um what I'm looking to do is remove
these from the
bill because these have to do with if
someone's done something
wrong
um I guess you know the the the
Authority for the initial part of of
looking into these uh problems
investigating stuff moved to oplc but
this language left it in the board and
with oplc is that a reasonable way of
putting it
yeah I think one of the interesting
things about the we refer to them as
charging statutes that's kind of if
you've done something wrong that's a
place where it's probably okay to have
it both in the oplc and the board
statutes so if if there exists language
that says this is a violation and you
can be held accountable this also deals
with the penalty which yeah I mean your
recommendation your email was to remove
these lines from the bill correct and I
you stick with that yeah I'm sticking
with that so that repeal don't repeal it
is basically don't repeal the language
from so remove it from the repeal line
correct correct repeal
section Mr chair would you like a motion
please I move that we retain lines
remove remove them from the bill which
would retain them inat remove
remove line item 37 and 38 from no 37
through Page seven line one page seven
line one thank you yeah they're they're
they're too adjacent but we I know I had
to switch the page in my brain okay uh
that's brown seconds uh all in favor
anyone oppose
okay I don't I don't want to Railroad
and vote for
everybody and make assumptions which are
dangerous so okay last one that in W
yeah um P okay now we're on to page
seven line two which is the last last
one of this section and this one is we
want to leave this in the bill um this
is the grandfathering statute for you
know grandfathering and lnas that were
licensed another way since we're keeping
LNA licensing we should remove this from
the bill so that it will remain in
statute I got that
right makes sense so remove I make a
motion to remove to leave it in the bill
to leave the line in the bill so we're
going to repeal it correct oh no no
actually no I'm I've got you're
absolutely right you're absolutely right
thank you yeah that's another one I got
finally I got it right no I'm
not okay so I there's a reason why we're
all doing this together I ask people to
review it we leave it no we remove it
from the bill
yeah remove it from the the way my brain
works is remove it from the repeal line
so that stays in the statute okay okay
so we have that motion let me one a
second all right um all in favor hi
anyone oppose no okay
so I will um yeah take this to O
Olaf and we'll have an amendment and
when I get the amendment
um when I get the amendment I will um
send it out to everybody and please take
a look at it um to make sure I didn't I
I'll be very careful but uh right for me
to whoops let me go back
to
lineage hang on hang on let me get to it
37 those from the B right we're removing
please we're removing them actually is
that
right right removing so that they stay
in statute so they stay in statute okay
right no that's good double check
reinforcing my double check is
good um all right so I am going to close
the subcommittee work session on House
Bill 14 1410 and as soon as I get my
things organized here actually I'll open
it on the work session of House Bill
1676 it'll just yeah but just give me a
moment here to change
gears no you're not on this
one no now this last one having some
extra eyes on it wasn't a bad thing um
okay
yes
um see membership
purpose okay so um you know it was a a
lively hearing um and
uh I I I can't speak for anyone
else um so my take is there were uh
three main objections the big one was
that uh people perceive the repeals in
the bill as a threat to you know
whatever board they think is important
share my apologies which bill number
again I'm sorry 1676 that's the sunset
one I'll wait till people get it if you
want yeah
I'm going to hand something around I'm
going to read this out for the people
here
but
yeah you can look at this and then no
this is something extra I want and hand
it down to people okay so there was a
concern about
the
repeals which I'm I think I'm going to
get to last there's a concern about the
membership which I completely agree with
and there was concern about uh the
stated purpose in the bill and I took a
I'd like to deal with that one
first um and and what I'd like to do
here is um deal with those issues and
then if anybody has any other on the
subcommittee has any other issues with
the bill they want to bring up we can
deal with them and then uh
then move on from there
so um the statement of purpose I can see
as uh some of it's I think boiler plate
that were put in all these bills maybe
not appropriately in all cases and so
the language I mean the the first
sentence I kept the protection of health
and safety is of utmost importance to
New Hampshire state government and
consumers of the state fine now it says
here you know the you can look at the
existing language but it's uh it says
over regulation there's a barrier can
prevent and the purpose this but it
states the purpose of this act is to
require legislature to reexamine the
licy boards of the state to determine if
it is in the best interest of the
consumers and the health and safety of
the state to renew their Authority so
that doesn't really go along with the
rest of the bill because it's it's it's
putting it out there like there's two
options one is we keep things the way
they are or we just get rid of them and
that is not the intent and so what I I'm
going to read what passed around but you
can look at it as well I have one cop
yeah I you can give it to Peter or or
someone out there if they want it or
whatever but I'll read it so the first
sentence is the same the protection of
health and safety is of utmost
importance to New Hampshire state
government and the consumers of the
state and then it says at the same time
the general court recognizes the right
of an individual to pursue a lawful
occupation is a fundamental right and
then lastly the purpose of this act is
is to require the legislature to
reexamine the licensing Boards of the
state to determine if the balance of
those two important interests has being
done properly and to suggest any
improvements oh my so that's not
presuming what the outcome is is going
to be correct and it's not saying
there's only two options All or Nothing
correct um and lays out the general
issues y i i I think you started out on
the right note by saying when I saw the
bill and said
Sunset swipe clean everything wipe
everything off the board and we don't
need that's a threat to the public
safety to begin with right now if you
read the if you read even the original
bill you know the body of the bill was
that the commission's supposed to you
know it's got all the things they're
supposed to look at and all the options
they can take one is to leave it alone
one is to get rid of it I would be very
surprised if uh such a commission would
actually eliminate all regulation uh of
any kind for the professions and that
wasn't the intent but I understand why
it was perceived that way and we'll get
to the repeal issue I've got suggestions
for that U but I at the moment I'd like
to just see if people are happy with
this change to the purpose I sorry I
will in a no rep you continue and then
we'll get to okay uh the I that makes me
really so much more comfortable because
I came in this morning thinking there's
no way we can get rid of Medical Board
starting from next year Sunset
everything I mean this is total never
intent yeah so uh I
think and this is a huge task just like
this uh body this committee did last
year Shifting the oplc responsibility to
oplc that was a major overhaul that took
this committee a lot I I was not on it
right but I can
see this cannot be done in a haste
correct and this would jeopardize the
safety and integrity of our licensing
system and and you get the the and how
to deal with repeals there's some other
stuff there to help with that so you
know the part of the reason it was
spread out is a concern that if the
commission had too much dumped on it too
quickly the easiest thing to deal with
it is just say leave everything alone
and not really take a good enough look
to see if there are changes needed um I
don't want that and I didn't expect
they're going to say well we'll just get
rid of it I mean that's um and and um
and what we did last year was more
looking at the overall structure of
Licensing and the relationship between
the boards and
oplc and we did some stuff I hope to
make that better this is having the
commission look at individual boards and
how what's going on there I mean they
could make recommendations for the
overall structure but it's more to look
at you know each profession and is what
we're doing making the right the correct
the best balance possible between public
health and safety and you know people's
right to to uh to work and for the
consumer's right to have people to do
the service yes yeah um so in that
regard don't you think it would be
prudent on this committee's part to say
major changes happened last year the
rule it hasn't been implemented oplc
hasn't taken over or the boards haven't
had a chance to readjust to the
new uh regulations or new roles and
responsibility instead of trying and
saying which one will go which one you
know let's put this in a interim study
and let's say okay let this will happen
so the next term it will have an at
least you would have had the rulle
making happen with major overhaul from
last term what I'd like to do yeah I I
would oppose that but um not that it's
completely up to me but um what I what
I'm asking if we can go through and deal
with these three issues and see if we
might still say because of that issue
you raised we don't want to pass this
bill now that's fine or for other
reasons whatever reason
but I'd like to go through um three
pieces and see you know if we feel this
would make you know be an improvement to
the bill if we chose to pass it and then
um then we can
address the overall recommendation to
the committee if if that's
okay so Mr chair do you want a motion on
this or just an agreement a motion on
this that that um the committee would
like to see the statement of purpose
changed in this way okay I actually
represent well you got a I do have brief
yeah okay Co thank you Mr chairman so uh
I think you're moving in the right
direction generally um but I I think
there are some aspects that need to be
addressed so I the first sentence I
think is needs to be changed to say the
citizens of this state not the consumers
because you can be somebody who's uh not
a consumer but you're going like this is
just wrong uh so I I think you should
say citizens but well if if I can
comment briefly just on that one I just
because somebody doesn't like it and
they say it's just wrong I don't know
that that's leg now now you could argue
that um you know somebody practicing
profession doing something wrong could
have a health and safety impact on
something somebody other than the
Consumer so I'm actually fine with
changing that
word right that I accept your offer yeah
so consumers out citizens in yeah uh
secondly yeah I know we could go through
it sentence by S you know okay the
second sentence ize the right of an
individual to pursue a lawful occupation
I I think that's also questionable
because uh some people could not
legitimately P pursue a lawful
occupation because they have a criminal
background uh that would I mean somebody
who's guilty of been convicted of
assault uh should not be uh in permitted
to to uh practice a profession where
they going to put hands on other people
well what yeah what I'm look what I
think this is trying to do is say there
I know where you're coming from I just
think to say uh the right of an IND
individual is absolutely in question
depending on what that individual's P
history is there there are limitations
on almost all right so I'd like uh
director Courtney or somebody from lplc
I recall and I you know before we did
all this stuff last year there was
somewhere in statute and I don't know if
it's still there that actually basically
made this statement that people had the
right and if you know where that is yes
it was in
332g was it 12 I believe it was repealed
as part of an amendment however
um I mean obviously you you've put that
amended language back in this bill
um I've always questioned though what
that actually means because when we talk
about fundamental rights we're thinking
about constitutional rights and you
can't create a constitutional right in
statute I think you know so the
fundamental right language is a term of
art
constitutionally um that said you know I
think it's it definitely demonstrates
that the legislature's intent which is
that the right to pursue an occupation
um is an important interest I mean would
you feel more comfortable if the word
fundamental were
removed I'll ask you and
then I mean I'm not uncomfortable with
the language generally I just don't I
just think that the fundamental right
speaks usually to substantive rights
established by the Constitution that's
why I was trying to deal with that issue
by taking the word out yeah I think he
would eliminate that confusion
grammatically that would be strange if
you just took that word out I think no
it's it would say and right to pursue a
lawful is a right yeah and that's not
grammatical I don't Mr chair I have a
fundamental question certain all right
fundament I have a fundamental question
so when you
say individual to pursue a lawful
occupation is a
right is that refering to not having
licensing not having any structure
I'm seeing it has just like my First
Amendment right or Second Amendment
right I don't need to be told how to
practice my profession am I totally off
or is my reading anywhere in the area I
I I can answer then if somebody else has
something but if you look at any of the
rights even the ones that are in the
Constitution um there's always you have
a right but there is um it can be
restricted if in you know to protect
things like public health and safety you
need to exercise the right in a
responsible manner I mean if my only
experience is a car mechanic and I'm
going to I'm want to practice brain
surgery clearly you know do I have a
right to in a sense you do but that
right can be limited everybody has that
General right but the right can be
limited if what you're going to do is
going to threaten public health and safy
so what I'm trying to do here is say
you know protecting public health and
safety is very important people have in
general a right to practice their
profession and what I'm looking for the
commission to do is to to look at how
we're balancing those to right are we
protecting public health and safety you
know well well enough um while still you
know in in intruding on that right as
little as necessary okay that and that's
done with almost any right I can't think
off hand of one maybe there's one but
one where that's not the case I I get
your point but practicing a profession
is a much more
responsible higher responsibility on the
practicing person's shoulder so I might
be a great Veterinary uh brain surgeon
can I just say oh I'm so good at brain
surgery I'm going to go do it on human
so you know what difference does it make
so that kind of you know we are in the
general area
so the light the way I'm looking at this
in a context of these commissions the uh
licensing why do we have these things to
protect the general public which is why
that which is the first line and the
second line when you say practicing a
professional is a fundamental right I
think it contradicts to some extent so I
could say hey I'm not allowed to
practice Speech Pathology
on animals whatever right and you know
that' be okay taking pH on out because
it has some right you know it's a term
of Art in law which might I could see be
an issue um but but I will in a moment
but actually after bre around but sorry
um and I don't want to go in circles but
you know anytime you're looking
at you it's up to the
legislature to do this balancing which
has been going on and all we're saying
is take a look at how it's being done
now and is it being done in the best way
right is it both protecting the public
and imping ing on people's right to to
work how they want the least and you
know I would guess that having a
Veterinary surgeon doing brain surgery
on people is the the you know the
commission and the legislature
determined that that's not you know
that's not adequately protecting public
health and safety I I would be amazed
and shocked if they said otherwise and
wonder what was going on but so with
that the whole language of the bill
established ing a sunset
commission well we we'll get to the
various occupation boards I mean the
whole this is what we did with the other
one reciprocity because the
whole the language of the
bill didn't Express what was really the
intent of the bill right we itell that I
don't know about I mean I I think the
intent there was we want as much
um um licensing by endorsement is
possible but it's got to make sense and
we gave the authority to oplc to
determine that through rul making and
they're in the middle of doing it and
I've actually reviewed it and I it's it
looks reasonable I haven't looked at it
in great detail hopefully there's a lot
of people I'm sure they are looking at
it but if in the end like any other rule
the legislature decides they didn't make
the right call the legislature has the
right and the ability to impose a change
but but I agree that that one you know
because they're in the middle of
actually implementing what we told them
to implement to let it play out this is
more dealing with the individual boards
and what we did last time was much
less you know changing what the
licensing is than more the
administrative structure within the
whole
department sir yeah one more and then I
got to let other people
yeah okay so just like what
did we did with the previous Bill where
the medical technician it didn't make
sense it didn't exist we pulled it out
right so that was and then we left LNA
which is great so that's what the LI
that's what the legislature does in this
case I think it's a
sweeping whopping change that the
legislation this particular bill is
saying change the fundamentally what we
are trying to do that's how I'm seeing
it so I can kind of see that I'll just
respond quickly and then Brown gold and
Schmid
um it it is
requiring a review of all of the boards
that are listed in there so in that
sense it's sweepy but the idea is what
they're told to do commission is just
look at each one individually I mean
they could do them in parallel what
however the commission decides to go but
but to take a look at the details of
each one and in the my change to the
statement of purpose the original one
seemed to imply an assumption that
either we're going to leave it the way
it is or get rid of it which was not the
rest of the bill doesn't say that and so
the statement of purpose was not
appropriate for the bill and it wasn't
the intended purpose so my intent here
is to say the job of the commission is
to take these two competing interests
clearly there's an interest in Pro in
protecting public health and safety and
there's an interest in you know people
do have the right to pursue their
profession unless you know unless
there's a reasonable government interest
in in in interfering I mean if if the
boards went too or oplc went too far and
limiting it you know people could sue on
that and and if it's you know
unreasonable what they're doing they
would probably win this is saying look
at it now and say do we think does the
legislature think in each case we're
striking that balance right and we're
doing it in an efficient way in a way
that protects public health and safety
while interfering with people working as
you know no more than
necessary and that and I my intent was
the purp you know the statement of
purpose that I revised one is intended
that so representative
Brown uh thank you Mr chair so um uh I
appreciate what you did here rewriting a
statement of
purpose every Bill we have that has a
statement of purpose I always read it
because somewhere down the road 10 years
down the road someone's going to say why
did you do this and that's kind of what
that statement of purpose is meant to
say why did we follow this path so I
like that you're trying to make it to
make it uh more sensible I think so
without upsetting anyone in the gallery
or creating an individual opinion here
here I will say that on line three in
the
original at the same time the general
court recognizes that over regulation is
a barrier to obtaining a
license it may be that the governor's
office feels that's the case and maybe
that's the impetus to some of this I'm
not speaking for the governor's office
but there are certainly a a number
of certain Representatives with a
political persuasion that would agree
with that statement
that if you're over regulating people
it's too hard for them to get a
license now could we add to your
language and you may disagree and that
just give me one more 30 seconds here
sure no so to your sentence where you
say at the same time dur Court recognize
the right of an individual to pursue a
lawful occupation could we add something
to the effect without burdensome
regulation or something of that nature
because that some that ENT is coming
from somewhere and um I think that there
is some support for that conversation in
the legislature I I I recognize that
um what I tried to do
is you know is which is sort of sat of
purposes should be relatively it's
represent G and then you is uh is you
know tend to be they should be I think
fairly General um and the issue around
over I mean overregulation
it's open to interpretation it's it's
kind of True by definition
overregulation is a barrier sure but but
it's a matter of you know and I'm this
doesn't make any um decision as to what
what is overregulation what isn't that's
the commission and then the legislature
but I think what you're looking for is
kind of included in the last sentence
the purpose of the ACT is to require the
legislature to reexamine the licensing
board to determine if the balance of
those important interests would be done
properly and suggests any Improvement
ments because you know if the commission
thinks there's overregulation then they
presumably think the balance isn't been
made appropriately and they would offer
some suggestions for legislation to to
fix that to make a change so I I'm I
don't you're not wrong but I'm resisting
trying to add more stuff in here on
specifics I don't think it's helpful I'm
uh thank you I'm okay with that I just
wanted to make sure we talked about it
represent thank you
thank you Mr chair
um
so I I really like I I started out with
like the change in this away from um the
language that we had that the bill came
to us
with and in talking with um some of the
folks who testified last time after the
hearing you know this totally changes
the flavor which is what they were
looking for was that we not start out
with the attitude of we're going to
eliminate some of the conversation I've
been listening to right now has sounded
a little partisan and I really hope we
can stay out of the partisan nature of
this and and all have a head toward
what's going to serve our um citizens
who are also consumers and by the way on
that word the thing earlier I wanted to
say is that I I would hope we also want
to protect visitors to our state who are
um partaking of any of the services
while they're passing through that they
also have a confidence they were
protecting them so I I don't think the
word matters so much as the protection
and and I kind of like what
representative um Brown was saying by
adding without the burden of
overregulation and you put the over in
there but I also agree with you that if
it's going to make it more partisan
sounding and um difficult for people to
be able to understand the concept here
which the concept is that we want to
protect the safety of the people and
lawful occupation means you follow the
laws it means you're not a murderer
child rapist trying to go in and do kind
job you're not doing something that's
illegal you're not selling is illegal ex
exactly so the lawful the word lawful in
there addresses that whole issue I like
taking fundamental out I like what um
we've talked talked about the whole
constitutionality issue versus uh
statute so anyway I I'd like to move
that that we adopt this amended language
if we can all agree to um a simple thing
and I and I'm aware I have to leave in
15 minutes and I'd like to help as much
as I can and that's actually going to be
a a process issue
um that we're spending more time I'm not
objecting but we're spending more time
on this than I expected and we have uh
even thornier issues to deal with I'm
okay and um and
and right I this
is I don't think this it's an FN is this
an early Bill I'd have to check with
Carol um but not all FNS
are uh she sent I don't have it with me
she sent an email that listed all the
bills in the subcommittees and I think
there was an Asis by the ones early well
we don't need to decide this here but
yeah the the issue is is timing
so we kind of agree not to meet on
Mondays and at this point I couldn't
schedule one on Monday anyway because I
think the 24-hour notice doesn't count
weekends I'm not sure so we couldn't
adequately notice it so we couldn't meet
on
Monday um I I can miss I can miss the
delegation meeting I think this is
important I agree
I I have another subcommittee that I
have to and in one sense I'd kind of
like to have um you know Glenn Glenn
here or a substitute if before we really
EXA controversial stuff
so how about this uh let's go through
this as far as we can and um yeah okay
and um you're going to leave I don't
know who else is going to leave but I
mean we could you're not on the
subcommittee I mean the issue is quorum
you're welcome to stay I'm just
understand but I can't because I have oh
when do you have to leave I have to be
there
2:00 an hour okay so okay I'm good today
till probably 2:30 I need to
go I understand
um how about this let's try and finish
um this one and then what I'll do is
I've got stuff written up on the other
two issues okay I will hand them out to
people um if we maybe discuss them a
little bit but then go off and think
about it and then I'll talk to Carol
about when we can schedule a meeting to
continue this just for your information
uh Mr chair um I moved all my
Monday
appointments so I will open it up
for subcommittee possibly if I know we
can't do this next mon well I'll I'll
talk to Carol something just so you know
that thank you for that thank you very
much for that um so something uh brief
representative Schmidt if
you right what one of the things that
needs to be said is that not every Bill
representative Brown not every bill has
a statement of Purpose By Any Means and
it is actually uh found upon in many
respects uh to do so because you see the
wrestling that we're engaged in and in
my re my view we have not at all dealt
with this question of this fundamental
rights situation I think it would be
much better to say for example at the
same time the general court recognizes
that the
interest of individuals to P pursue
lawful Prof occupations is
fundamental it ain't a question of
Rights folks because because not every
individual has a right to do anything
that's lawful um there there too many
qualifications so anyway I I say my
language would be better better than
what you have and you can't get over the
problem that I alluded to about the
words the word right anyway we we'll
have to disagree actually on that okay
but anyway I still think my so it's not
a right you may can have an interest you
thought it was better if or you wouldn't
have brought it Forward I get it okay so
but but also the commission of course
can't remove anything it can only
propose right that's the other thing
right right it can't do anything it can
only propose stuff so I'm I'm completely
fine with taking the word fundamental
out uh director Courtney raised a good
point on that um as far as uh consumer
and
citizen I lean a little more to Consumer
and the reason is although I is that the
issue of people coming the state there's
still going to be consumers here
um would you I mean yeah if you have a
suggestion I well I agree would you
consider someone that lives in
Massachusetts that has a license in New
Hampshire working here a consumer and if
that's the case then it makes sense
this well if they're practicing in New
Hampshire they're working for some
consumer in the state of New Hampshire
right so I'm okay with you see the the
you see the issue with
with statements of purpose and this this
one is fundamentally heard that I mean
you if everyone wants to removal we
could I thought on this one because
there seemed to be some confusion about
why we're doing this having having
something here I thought would be of
some some value um I'm not saying it
isn't but also I think the question of
workability which I addressed in my
remarks to the committee when the bill
was heard the the idea that you're
setting up a test ask for the commission
to examine all the boards is unworkable
that's a separate question we're not
addressing that question right now so
please yes Mr chair so the key point in
this bill is to establish a commission
to
evaluate various occupational
boards instead of saying establishing a
sunset commission EV evaluate the
board
boards
and assess
the efficacy
and uh wh why you know my question is
why
is sunsetting is the key point I get
that so that's not in the statement of
purpose but if you want to when we meet
again if you want to come forward with a
different name for the commission I'm
certainly open to that and we could
change it wherever it's used um and I I
get the concern um because it seems to
imply I mean this has been used in a
number of other states the idea
is is you set up the repeal and then the
commission to review it and it's to push
the process and so it's sunsetting but
it's only going to Sunset if the
commission wants it to or doesn't do
doesn't say it should continue but I I
get the concern in the message so if you
could think of something else you'd like
to call it for next time one question so
each board don't they have the
evaluatory uh clause in their function
to say how efficient we are or not to
look that this is to look I mean also
that got in the question we had last
time on uh performance audits like we
had with the Dental Board um that's
looking there is the board operating
efficiently under the current statute do
the rules go along with the statute and
all that has anything changed are they
doing things that they shouldn't for
example and that's good but this is to
step back and take a look at the whole
structure okay of how we're
regulating um you know this and there's
a number of ways of doing it and what
we're doing currently is certainly one
way and maybe the commission will decide
that it's going to stay the same maybe
with some tweaks or not but it's a
matter of stepping back because you know
if you're looking at at like a
performance audit you're in the weeds
saying are they doing what the
legislature told them to do and are they
doing it well but this is stepping back
and saying should the legislature change
somewhat what we're telling them to do
or or how to regulate so that that's um
Mr chair yeah might I back up just to
Tad certainly so I I think uh
representative that what you were trying
to say is what the last sentence of the
proposed statement of purpose does say
yeah reexamine the licensing boards you
use the different word but same idea
reexamine the licensing boards to
determine if the balance of those
interests is being done so I think that
that's what you were getting at correct
and I think that this says this well and
if you want while we still have a quorum
I I did we do a I would if we didn't do
a motion I would motion we accept this
statement of purpose as written with
they change to the fundamental
right
um as as
you somebody else if somebody else would
like to Second yeah but you know it's if
it can would that uh if it's strike
that which the second line fundamental
right that's what the chair I would
strike fundamental I would leave in
right um but it it doesn't you know it
reduces can we just say individual to
pursue a lawful occupation in the state
and leave it at that rather than saying
it's indiv I mean that actually does say
I mean I at the same time the general
court Riz the right of an individual to
pursue a lawful occupation is a f so
it's saying right twice yeah if You' be
okay to amend your motion I'd be fine
with taking the is a fundamental write
out just leave strike that I'm okay with
that okay okay so so going to amend your
moot your motion yeah amend my motion to
end the sentence at occupation right and
right correct
correct thank you and the purpose of
this act is to require the legislator
reexamining State DET if the balance of
those important interest is being done
properly
yeah that you know this commission okay
purpose of this commission is to
require the because the whole
legislature is not looking at it it's we
are authorizing a commission to take a
look at it right but they can only
propose changes in the end the
legislature will have to review any
proposed changes and they can modify
them or get rid of them or whatever they
want the whole legisl want correct but
that is the purpose of the commission
the duty of a commission or the role of
a commission is to just recommendation
that's already in the statute correct
correct so commissions cannot propose uh
language for law or change
something the commission the commission
can propose legislation to do anything
to the legislature to the leg but they
can't they can't Implement anything
correct so all they do is issue a report
yeah so instead of saying the purpose of
this act is to require the
legislator require the commission to re
if you want to change that because it's
not the whole legislature is not that's
I'm fine with that
okay did you get that's under the
assumption that we will leave that it
called a commission we're calling I
think it'll be called a commission we
might change the name of the commission
but correct I'm okay that's fine yeah
because the commission the
responsibility is to overse right so
that's fine that makes sense yeah and
then I will change this whole thing no
Sunset commission well that's right
that's that's a different question so we
are looking at statement of purpose just
that section and so I'll I'll read what
I think with these changes I've got and
so the protection of health and safety
is of utmost importance in New Hampshire
state government and the consumers of
this state at the same time the general
court recognizes the right of an
individual to pursue a lawful occupation
the purpose of this act is to require
the commission to re-examine the
licensing Boards of the state to
determine if the balance of those
important interests is being done
properly and to suggest any improvements
so oh something where word popped up at
this so at the same time the general
court recognizes that the right of an
individual to pursue a lawful occupation
in the state well our authorities in the
state and we don't need to okay I have
great sympathy to the people drafting
the the Declaration of Independence at
this point but
um so which they went through the same
process I understand it from history but
but which which is fine I mean people
need to be
comfortable so we have a you're okay
with that yes that's your motion so can
we have a second all right cool all
right um so um all in favor I okay
nobody opposed anyone
opposed okay thank you and I apologize
to drag everybody in there and not get
any further than we did but it it is
what it is um so what I'm going to do is
talk to representative Maguire chair
Maguire about scheduling and figure out
um where we go from here for members of
the committee
subcommittee I'm going to pass
out um a couple things and one of them I
actually going to I have a change um but
I
don't uh you know I've only pen in one
of them so I'm going to have to tell you
what it is so one of these um the first
one is and I've gotten all disorganized
is actually to talk about the membership
so the real problems with the membership
that was
proposed uh before this meeting so I
just need three so one for you thank you
one for
representative all right so
um I I spoke with uh chair Maguire this
morning and she suggested a
change uh one change and that is um I'll
I'll
quickly so it's uh two members the house
of of Edna one of whom shall be a
minority applied by the speaker one
member of the House Commerce consumer
affairs appointed by the speaker and
often in a lot I looked at other
Commissions in law and usually if it's
three legislators it requires one be
from the minority so I added that that
was a good catch uh similarly for the
Senate two members of the Senate Ed one
will be in the minority and one member
from Senate Commerce and then a public
member representing the interest of
businesses in New
Hampshire um appointed by the Bia this
okay um the exe uh U director Courtney
or design you know the the executive
director and I had in there three
members of the public appointed by the
Governor uh represent mire suggestion is
to drop that to two and add one public
member representing a healthare a
healthare healthcare employers appointed
by the governor um
and and that leaves it an odd number
it's 11 which is I think it tends to be
a good a good number for the for a
commission uh meets the Le the uh statut
requirement it can't be more than 15 uh
there's a statut requirement legislators
have to the majority which they are six
out of
11 um and then for the public member
it's got the usual language they can't
be a liy or involved in licensing they
have to represent the public basically
consumers what did you say about sorry I
change this to two uh two and then
underneath one public member
representing um Healthcare employers
appointed by the governor and counsel
you know um I I I like this change one
of the things that I was looking at the
original one was that Governor gets to
do two members and again Governor gets
to do three public members I did get
this bill well I'm very interested in
this and I've thought of this idea for
some years and I support it I got the
actual language from the governor's
office and the charge of the commission
the duties of the commission I I looked
at very carefully and had some changes
for I admit I did not carefully review
the members which I should have and no I
I don't agree with what was there so
um you know that was not yeah
I you know as much I like or don't like
the governor I didn't want to give him
too much power on this not my intent
sorry so um we've had our differences
but I I would make a motion to accept uh
chairman Le has Chang someone like to
speak on this second wait wait yeah okay
we've got the motion second but sorry
we're not trying
to and actually yeah if somebody has
suggestions on this I I apologize for
not doing that first you're trying to
move it along Steve ran Court um from
pelman Hampshire um we just feel it's a
little bit possibly unfair with that
makeup the governor's already appointing
two at the beginning and you've
appointed no I I if let me read through
this we completely replaced that the
language and the bill is gone if if we
do this so it would be uh three members
from the house uh two members from Edna
one of whom from the minority party a
minority party and then one member of
house from oh great Commerce okay and so
that's three members of the legislature
two from Edna one from Commerce and one
of the Eda ones have to be from the
minority party and same thing for the
Senate three Senators two from Edan one
have to be for the minority one from
Commerce and then a public member
representing the interests of business
in New Hampshire appointed by the Bia
and that's in this kind of language is
in other commissions I actually went
back and looked at number of them um and
then uh you know the executive director
of oplc or
design and then what's WR I'm written
there but the intent is to change it it
says three members of the public
appointed by the governor that would be
changed to two members just general
members appointed by the governor
although there's language down below
saying the public members you know can't
have a direct interest in licensing I
mean they're to represent basically the
consumers and then add on to it one
public member representing a healthcare
employer and appointed by the governor I
was thinking about having the
appointment be by the hospital
Association but talking with chair
McGuire the problem is there are a
number of other interests in healthcare
employers not just the
hospitals and while the governor would
do the appointment it's got to be
somebody representing a healthcare
employer so G Bia is just general all
you know all kinds of employers but
since a lot of the boards deal with
Health Care stuff um she felt and I
agree that it should there should be
somebody there who is more knowledge
from the healthcare employer side of the
fence so that reduces the governor's
appointments from five to three right
and one of them is constrained and that
they have to be um representing a
healthcare employer it just feels like
the um we're doing the healthcare side
of it but forgetting the professional
side they're pretty even the amount of
boards I don't know if they're trying to
use the Bia the consider the
professional side yeah I mean we're not
the intent as I said during the public
hearing licensing is not for the people
licensed at all I mean it hopefully will
have some positive benefits to encourage
you know education further development
and all that and and maybe there's some
Prestige or trust that's good but the
legal the legitimate purpose for
licensing is to protect public health
and
safety so anyway that's if I may sir
certainly of course uh thank you Mr
chair so I I I hear what you just said
so in here we have electricians
electrology genetic counselors Midwifery
naturopathic many well those are those
are Healthcare some of them but many
that aren't
Health Engineers Architects all of them
I just feel that it should be some
balance if we're going to represent the
healthc care industry even though
they're not licensed there should be one
for well nonprofessional we're looking
for one person that commissions don't
work if they're too big and there's
actually statutory limitations on the
size chair could we so um my question
would be is do is there another
organization besides the Bia maybe there
somebody better but there's nothing I'm
better be able to appoint the a couple
you know billing associations that are
probably more represent the professional
side than than the Bia you know I mean
ABC AGC things like that that might if
you're going to appoint to something
like that what again and this is no
disrespect to anybody or their trade or
their license but
it's not the intent isn't to represent
the people who are licensed it's the
people who are the who who make use of
them and business and industry as well
as individual consumers do as well as
healthc care employers so that's why
those two we're in there now maybe
there's somebody some organization
that's more representative of businesses
in general as they use you know those
aren't those aren't licensed the AGC ABC
Construction general contracts they're
not Li Li so it's not a licensed
individual on there and it would
represent the business industry better I
think but the the issue I have I'll get
you in just a moment the issue I have is
that we can't make it too big really
there's room for one we look one Health
one was healthcare because they're like
a lot of the lenses are Healthcare
probably in numbers probably especially
with nursing um you know the majority so
maybe consider changing the viia to
something else leave it like I'm I'm
open to suggestions on that and
represent yeah yes so in supporting that
um I think that your second line says at
the same time the general court
recognizes the right of an individual to
pursue a lawful occupation so we know
that as much as the primary goal is
protecting the safety of the uh citizens
and the the state and that licensing is
really important we
also there's no way to know whether
there's a a balance if we don't have the
right uh agencies and we've heard over
and over D jurus has come in and other
members of the governor's office to talk
about some of the problems with the
appointment process through the
governor's office and the problems the
public has of getting a hold of them so
I really like what you've done by um by
picking an organization I think we need
to work on the right Organization for
the professionals and for the hospital
person I I want to challenge that there
is a medical profession that can do it a
direct appointment when we have
commissions and committees where
appointments are done outside the
governor's office it's much easier for
the professionals and the public to
access and get their appointments done
than it is if we get bottlenecked in the
thousands and thousands and thousands of
appointments the governor's office is
doing I mean if you can come up with a
some health some maybe an organization
that represents Healthcare organizations
it's maybe broader than the hospital
Association that'd be great
and and that would then would pull it
completely out of the governor's hands
which I'm okay with um representative
yeah the couple of comments I do you
know to
stakeholders not just the consumers and
the providers but the industry experts
is also necessary the you know I
understand your uh intent of health care
because there's a large portion of it
and that really affects the safety in
wellbeing uh same time like the
engineering uh you know uh professions
which is not Healthcare that should also
be represented but I do appreciate the
fact that not the whole all the eggs are
in one basket that everything comes from
the governor's office that was taken
away so and maybe the restriction or
suggestion to the governor's office can
be given
to appoint the two appointees that they
get be from different professions so
right well no it explicitly says the
public members may not hold a license or
have a spouse who holds a license or as
a financial interest in a
business uh in a licensed profession if
you look at the paragraph under the
bullets which is pretty standard for
most public standard for public members
I mean that you look at any one of the
the uh the board makeups for any the
boards that I took that language from I
think one of the other boards I I have
to challenge that thing just like you
know
the legislation is a volunteer
legislation and you can't you know we
can't say oh you can't if you're working
in the health care profession you can't
bring any bills in the health care
that it's a lot of volunteers that want
to work so when you say general public
without
you know you're kind of excluding the
large portion so are you looking at just
people who have retired or who are
emerging and not the consumers if they
hold license in some part the general
public I might hold license in health
care but I might be appointed for
different not as a health
um but but if I may Mr chair just if
you're having this commission and
they're going to determine whether or
not they should sunset or whatever
they're going to do to this thing and on
this list there's still nobody that has
any professional experience to give to
Insight to it so that's going to address
that and and so uh I you know I'll ask a
fous question which is you know do you
believe that uh that nobody in any of
the licensed professions or their uh
representatives are going to show up and
provide information to the commission I
mean the the intent is not to put
everybody who might have expertise
that's important to the commission on
the commission I mean that just that'd
be impossible so the idea is the
commission is um you know legislators
who are representatives of the the
people in general um and a member from
oplc that kind of have to be there
they're involved in all of it and then
so the idea then was and have public
members who aren't licensed who are
there to represent the general public
and then it's kind of
and then who else not the lies but who
else who are in effect consumers and the
thought was that you have you know
there's a lot of businesses both healthc
care is one set and then everybody else
who hire a lot of licensed people and so
they you know having some
representative on there from those
groups um you know would make sense but
you know they're going to have public
like any commission they have public
hearings they take input a written uh in
input public hearings uh public meetings
the whole deal like any
commission um and the whole process is
public and then they come out with a
recommendation uh but then that goes to
the legislature and through the co-
legislative process um and I understand
I appreciate Mr chair but if you take it
this committee and you say to them
what's the institutional knowledge it's
going to help them make some of these
decisions where is that I'm not looking
for it to be on the commission I'm
looking to the people who come before
the commission to provide it
Mr and that's true you look at you look
at this makeup of a lot of the
commissions we have on on a wide range
of subjects and that's generally what's
there they're not trying to put the
people with the institutional knowledge
on the
commission the the may I sir certainly
yeah the intent of that to remain
impartial well I so I'm I I I very much
agree with what this gentleman is saying
here in in
philosophy there should be someone on
this commission that has a clue about
the industry you I would think should
probably say the professional
professional and occupational side
should have one appointment and the
governor should have a third one for
whatever he wants and that would be
balanced it doesn't have to be a
licensed person whatever but from that
side of it somebody representing the
occupational somebody representing the
professional you need some sort of
institutional knowledge and it's I
understand the public meetings but you
know how hard it is and how much money
it costs us to come to these it cost me
$1,000 a day every time I come here not
working my guy not working lost job so
it's not easy to follow every one of
them especially the amount that's going
on now so while that's available it's
very hard to stay on top of it at least
if somebody's there they're watching out
and giving that input so they understand
how this would affect either one of
those that's all yeah and also also I
mean I I'm we have people in these
meetings on licensing regularly who have
orange badges so I assume are
representing hired to represent the
interests of the various group of
licenses and and I am sure that there's
going to be you know some of them
present who would be doing that that's
that's my take on it Mr chair follow up
all right you follow
up but and and and I also agree with I'm
agreeing with both sides which isn't
helpful probably but the impartiality of
a commission is not is also a good thing
could we without increasing the size of
this commission could we take your last
bullet which is now two members and
maybe make one of those appointed by the
governor
from an association not uh not
Association but a group not associated
with Healthcare or we give the Bia too
although you didn't think to be let me
let me make a large we're not going to
take a vote on this today okay I brought
this out to people to get this kind of
discussion going get people thinking
about it and then when we meet again so
you know if people have specific and I'm
not wedded to this membership okay um
there's certain principles on it um that
I am I mean I don't want you know
somebody from each one of the licensed
professions on here or something but if
there's a better way to make and we have
to have the majority of them have to be
legislators and we can't have more than
15 unless we want to override the
statute um so I'm just putting this out
and there's other things to discuss in
this which with lunch hour coming and
people having commitments we're not
going to get to so this is just to put
it out there so it's not sprung
unexpectedly on people certainly my one
little thing was um the two public
members appointed by the governor we
dropped it from 3 to
two in my experience those would be the
ones who would represent the general
consumer and shouldn't be licensed or
have any conflict but the business
industry person and the public health
person you would want of course licensed
professionals who understand the
profession and exactly for the reason
the gentleman said I was most moved in
one of the last hearings by the fact
that um our boards and committ misss are
volunteers and that when we're combining
them all we're wasting people's time if
they have to deal with unrelated matters
so the respecting their time and I think
is an important factor and thank you sir
for bringing that up I I agree entirely
and while I'm not going to prejudge what
we're going to do with the bill we heard
then um I will say that
um you
know at least the land survey and and
and the engineer merge seem well we'll
get to it but I'm not pushing for that
let's put it that way okay
representative thank you uh Mr chair
again with this I mean the intent is
predominantly the responsibility is put
on the legislators to look at it take a
hard look at what we have on the books
right now and make any suggestion so I
see your intent of uh three uh six of 11
so far would be legislators and then the
others are outside the legislation uh
legislators so I I see that but it's
also do we are we going to put a time
frame for the commission to work because
one of the things we we have a lot of
commissions but there is no uh you know
end it it everything starts and no yeah
so this one has to be a short yeah so f
it for the commission the third thing I
was going to hand out relates to that
okay and and I don't think we're going
to be able to debate this and I think
this is going to be a long one I'm just
handing out for people to think about uh
but in general terms and there may need
to be some tweaking what it would say is
that um if the commission you know the
commission's required to issue a report
on each one of these boards and the
requirement in here is they issue it at
least a year before the repeal date I
I'd like to leave the repeals in general
in there but to loosen this up so what
it what the change that I'm proposing is
to say if the um commission does not
issue their report by the date required
by the bill by Statute if it went
through then the repeal date for that
board for which did get a report is
extended by a
year so and there may be other way
that's a whole different discussion I'm
not going to get into that what I'm
saying is I recognize the concern I mean
I don't personally it's my opinion I
don't think it's a real realistic that
the board's the commission's not going
to do anything and then nobody's going
to put in a be Bill to repeal the repeal
okay I mean in my view personally no no
no disrespect to anybody's I think
that's fantasy but I could be wrong I
recognize that but so I'm trying to deal
with that but still have something that
that at least in some sense puts
pressure on the commission to actually
do something
is my fear I I think Mr chair yeah I
mean with all due respect I do
think your your presumption is that
commission is not going to do it so we
have to build the Safeguard I would like
to take the opposite view of saying we
are coming together as legislators to
say there is a commission we want you to
to a hard take a hard look and this is a
volunteer commission and and instead of
just throwing everything at them and get
rid of all these 57 boards uh 165 boards
or repeal it or keep it let's say hey
look at it on a general purpose and
making it more manageable and
expectation realistic expectation of the
commission so so my response would be
this is spread out over a number of
years I mean what I did not want is to
say oh look at all the boards and you
got a year or two to do it I mean that
that makes no that is unworkable and I I
agree um so it's spread over quite a
number of years and a piece at a
time um so I my tell was that would help
with that um as far as commissions doing
things or not doing things I you know I
I hope for the best and I um I think you
know everybody intends to do the right
thing but people have competing things
for time and interest and all that and
unfortunately if you look at the history
of commissions some have been great and
some not so much they haven't done a lot
and you can talk to Tom Dole and his
committee has been reviewing them so um
I you know it's like trust are going to
do the right thing but try and add some
pressure that's what I and and I would
just add quickly one of my thoughts is
why can't these tasks be given to Tom
Dolan's committee they've already they
have a very different charge their char
charg is to look at the existing
commissions and evaluate whether it's
worthwhile in committees to keep them
this is looking at something very
different which is how we're handling
regulation of professions in order to
protect the public health and safety
they're completely different in my yeah
the commissions are very different that
like the
veterans no no they're not licensing
they're also reviewing committies they
committe committees and commissions yeah
and not licensing boards commiss my my
my understanding the differences
distinction committees are all
legislators commissions can have non-
legislator members that's the thing I
think that's in statute we look but yeah
but I he the
on Mr chair if you put that in place the
one year what happens if by some chance
just looking forward addressing her
concerns after that one year they still
do would it continue to it's a weaker
thing I don't i' personally I'd prefer
leaving the repeals in with a fixed date
but I understand that generates a lot of
concern and there's some legitimate
issues there I get it so yes if the
commission never met and and that
basically the repeal dates would move
out a year to time on all the boards
until a committee like Tom Dolan said
this thing isn't working kill it um Mr
chair yeah I don't think you read maybe
you did the following
sentence actually sorry but for to this
gentlem to this gentleman's point it's
respect people's time and let them know
it says no board may be repealed without
the sunset commission delivering a
report on it yes that's the following
sentence which he didn't read right
right and and what I would say is that
first par paragraph implies the second
but I added that line there just to make
it absolutely clear what the situation
was that's that's the deal on that so
I'm going to um close the uh excuse me
Mr chair when how do we get this
information to people that are
interested in it um I would say what I
would like to do is not do that that
that for this thing if you have
suggestions we can re you know think
about them bring them to the
subcommittee meeting because what comes
out of it may be very different than
what I I wrote up okay I'm not claiming
that I'm going to speak for the
subcommittee or the whole committee
that's the deal I agree with you before
we as a subcommittee decide on something
it's it's it's not prudent to hand out
anything because that could go wild
thank right because we may go a very
different direction probably will and
that would leave something out there
that would assume that we want to do
whatever we aren't
doing thank you Mr chair all right I'm
I'm uh closing the subcommittee work
session on House Bill
1676 thanks for everybody for being here
um sorry that it maybe didn't get as
much done as might have been hoped but
it's a tough thing I mean I'm not that's
not I'm not criticizing anybody giving
at
all because it's yeah thank you Mr chair
for doing that yeah I looked at the list
of bills on this one I'm like